THAT WAS GORGEOUS.
>> THAT WAS ABSOLUTELY
BEAUTIFUL.
>> BEAUTIFUL PERFORMANCE.
NOW, THE MOMENT WE HAVE ALL
BEEN WAITING FOR.
LET'S BRING OUT OUR TOP TEN
HONOREES.
BACK TO THE STAGE, TO REVEAL
OUR 2022 CNN HERO OF THE YEAR.
>> SO --
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> SINCE WE ANNOUNCED THE TOP
TEN HEROES, WE GAVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE FOR THE
HERO THAT INSPIRES YOU, THE
HERE THAT IS RECEIVED THE MOST
VOTES WILL BE AWARDED AN
ADDITIONAL $100,000 TO CONTINUE
THEIR LIFE-CHANGING WORK.
THIS YEAR THANKS TO OUR
COLLABORATION WITH THE --
PRIZE FOUNDATION WHO MISSION IS
TO MAKE GOOD FAMOUS AND A
MEDICAL ALMARANTE IN, THE CNN
HERO WILL ALSO RECEIVE HUNDREDS
TREATED GRANT.
>> ALL TEN HONOREES WILL
RECEIVE CRITICAL, NONPROFIT
TRAINING AND ONGOING SUPPORT
AND ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
>> NOW, THE 2022 CNN HERO OF
THE YEAR IS --
>>.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[SCREAMING] >> ♪ ♪ ♪
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
THERE.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> OF COURSE, OF COURSE.
>> CAN SHE BE ONSTAGE?
>> YES!
>> >> [CRYING] >> [APPLAUSE]
>> AND NOW, IN FRONT OF THE
WHOLE WORLD I WANT TO SAY NEW
THIS SONG, ONE MORE TIME.
>> ♪ ♪ ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> SO, EVERY --
>> MY DEAR MOM ONLY MADE IT
THROUGH SIXTH GRADE, SHE CAN
BARELY READ AND WRITE.
SHE HAS FOUR DAUGHTERS AND SHE
WORKED REALLY HARD TO EDUCATE
US.
SCHOOLS IN KENYA ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE.
SO, PEOPLE WERE TELLING HER,
YOU ARE SO LUCKY YOU HAVE
GIRLS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
BUYING LAND FOR THEM, RIGHT?
YOU THEY CAN JUST GET MARRIED.
SO, BUT SHE REALLY BELIEVED IN
EDUCATING US.
SHE WOULD SLAVE AWAY, WORK
REALLY HARD, BY THE ROADSIDE.
SHE WAS BY THE ROADSIDE FOR
FOUR DECADES.
SO WHEN SHE COMES HOME I AM FOR,
I'M FIVE.
I SEE HOW EXHAUSTED SHE IS.
I THINK TO I SAY TO HER THIS
SONG THAT HAS MY HANDS ARE SO
TINY, I CANNOT HELP YOU BUT
WHEN I GROW UP I'M GOING TO
SHOW YOU THE WORLD.
SHE IS LIKE, YOU ARE SO CUTE.
RIGHT?
>> [LAUGHTER] >> RIGHT NOW, IN
FRONT OF THE WHOLE WORLD I AM
SINGING YOU I WILL SHOW YOU THE
WORLD.
THE CNN HEROES, YOU HAVE MADE
THIS HAPPEN.
--
>> [APPLAUSE]
.
>> I HAVE TO --
>> >> [APPLAUSE]
>> I DID NOT --
I DID NOT HAVE MUCH, I DO NOT
HAVE MUCH GROWING UP.
BUT I HAVE A LOT OF STUFF,
PEOPLE IN MY LIFE.
MY MOM, THE MOST --
IN THE WORLD.
JANE AND STEVE, WHEN I CAME TO
AMERICA FOR THE FIRST TIME I
WAS SO SCARED.
I WASN'T TALKING, I MADE MYSELF
SMALL.
YOU TOOK ME IN AS A MEMBER OF
YOUR FAMILY.
YOU TOOK ME IN, YOU HOSTED ME,
YOU HELPED ME SO MUCH.
WHEN I SAID --
AFRICA.
YOU ARE THERE TO PICK UP THE
NAME IT FOR MY LOVELY LIFE
PARTNER TYLER, I THINK WHERE
THE MOST SELFLESS PERSON IN THE
WORLD.
YOU ARE THE MOST TALENTED
SOFTWARE ENGINEER.
YES, YOU LEFT YOUR TOP JOB IN
CHICAGO AND JOINED ME IN
MOGOTIO.
LIFE HAS BEEN REALLY HARD FOR
YOU IN MOGOTIO, I SEE THAT.
I SAW HARD YOU WORK FOR AFRICA
AND PEOPLE THINK I'M SELFLESS,
BUT YOU HAS NO CONNECTION TO
MOGOTIO YOU DID NOT HAVE ANY
CONNECTION TO KENYA, YET YOU
LEFT.
YOU LEFT.
YOU COULD BUILD A COMPANY IN
THE NIGHT, THAT IS HOW TALENTED
TYLER IS.
BUT JUST TO LEFT ALL OF THAT TO
COME